[Music]
under new California law people will be
allowed to register to vote and it'll
happen actually automatically when they
obtain or renew their drivers license
regardless of whether they're US
citizens as leftist politicians
important voters they still don't seem
to understand that they're actually
dangers when this happens and the latest
evidence an illegal immigrant uber
driver was arraigned just yesterday he's
alleged to have raped and robbed four
young women
in San Luis Obispo let's get into this
now with New York Times bestselling
author and Coulter in New York and here
in studio with me is Jose Ortiz demonio
who's a former deputy national press
secretary for the Democratic Party
Jose let's start with you on this
registering people to vote who are here
illegally explain that one to me well
let's be clear here this policy that's
gonna be implemented in April this is
what's gonna happen voters if you are in
the country and you're in document that
you can gain a driver's license in
California right you already but right
but there are federal limitations
including you cannot register to vote if
you're an undocumented immigrant in
California and they were very clear the
state of California has been very clear
you will not be eligible to vote if
you're an undocumented immigrant it's
that simple and why is the big fuss if
that's all it is it's you real lot
you'll be eligible but you can't vote
yes illegal aliens are big rules
followers even before California was
issuing driver's licenses to illegals
and automatically registering them to
vote there are big Hispanic
organizations and leftist organizations
generally in California in the 90s that
managed to steal an election from Bob
Dornan I mean they found hundreds of
illegally registered to vote illegal
aliens who were voted for already 60% of
about 60% of all ballots in California
are sent in by mail it's not even the
illegal aliens who need to go and vote
don't worry they'll be voted for you
just need them registered to vote and
why did Trump close that voter
Commission because the states would not
cooperate you know the voter fraud
commission they made a big deal of it
the left kind of mocked him and then it
closed it was that because states just
wouldn't give the information or they
couldn't find any evidence or what was
it I'm I'm not sure
but I don't think it was a good idea
except that I think it might have just
been moved to an official investigation
with with the Department of Justice
incidentally because of California's
giving driver's licenses to illegal
aliens you know people are always saying
oh it's so burdensome for people to have
to have to get an ID in order to vote
well now all legal residents of
California are required to now get a
secondary ID in addition to their
driver's license because of a federal
law that says hey all of you states that
are issuing phony ID laws we need a real
one now so there's now the real driver's
license you have to go into the inner
circle of hell and register for all over
again and when they start giving that to
illegal aliens we'll have to have the
real Real ID so they don't mind
burdening their citizens that way but
yes if this is all about voting illegal
immigration legal immigration but
certainly illegal immigration daca
it is 100% about voting at least
California makes leads no everything's
you saying it's false the reality here
is that this new policy that's been
implemented in in California what it's
happening here this is about democracy
this is about registering people to vote
there are four to five million people in
California who are eligible to vote we
need to get them registered that is
about the monkeys not about the
undocumented me and the community it's
about the United States of America
every two new immigrants to the United
States on average sponsor about seven
family members so not not we're not
talking about spouses and minor children
that's always been respected and
time-honored tradition in American
immigration but what the president is
very concerned about is that of the
million green cards that are given out
every year annually more than four
hundred thousand of those are this kind
of extended family chain migration now I
know you originally came from Venezuela
or your parents came from Venezuela but
that's a minor child with parents we're
talking about uncles cousins and most
Americans are against that that's gonna
be a big part of this ongoing
immigration debate where do you stand on
this look that fine we can we can
negotiate the Democrats have been trying
to negotiate with the president every
single chair just took the wall off the
negotiating table that's gone he just
agreed to it now he took it off look you
want to talk about so
buddy who's on/off all the time that's
Donald Trump we don't know what he's
what do you mean he shut down the gut
Lee he shut down the government we know
that he said before that this will be
good for America won the whole debate I
majora maryam to know that this was the
this was the government for this was
that's why when the GOP controls the
White House you guys control the
Congress all right guys I wish we could
have an hour on this subject